وفي تاكيد امريكي على اولويه وقف اطلاق
النار قال المتحدث الاقليمي باسم الخارجيه
الامريكيه سامويل في مقابله مع الجزيره
قال ان بلاده لديها ادوات للضغط على طرفي
الصراع بما في ذلك العقوبات لكنه اشار الى
ان الاهم هو وجود صوت موحد من طرف المجتمع
الدولي لفرض وقف اطلاق النار
لدينا بعض الادوات واريات مثل الاقوبات او
تصنيف بعض الكائنات في لاهره كوبات لدينا
هذه الادوات واليات احداث جانب ولكن اهم
واقوى من كل ذلك او من اي ضغط يمارسها اي
بلد او يمارسه اي بلد بنفسه الاهم شيء
الصوت الموحد الصوت الموحد الرساله
الموحده بين كل دور بين كل الدول وكل من
كل انهاء العالم من المجتمع الدولي من ولد
المتحده الامم المتحده دوله اوروبيه دوله
خليجيه رساله واضحه للاطراف اطلاق النار